في تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا اعلنت
هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان القوات
الروسيه تواصل تركيز جهودها الرئيسيه على
اتجاهات الايمان باخموت ومارينكا مشيره
الى استمرار القتال العنيف في تلك المناطق
واضافت هيئه الاركان ان القوات الروسيه
شنت غاره بطائره مسيره من نوع شاهد الليله
الماضيه دون ان تحدد المنطقه المستهدفه
هذا ونشرت وكاله نوفسكي الروسيه مقطعا
مصورا يظهر ما قالت انه استهداف المدفعيه
الروسيه بدعم من المسيرات مواقع للقوات
الاوكرانيه في سبرودجاج جنوبي اوكرانيا
كما افادت السلطات المواليه لروسيا في
سبالوجيا بان الدفاعات الجويه تتصدت
لاهداف معاديه في سماء مدينه ميليتو بول
دون سقوط ضحايا او اصابات او وقوع اضرار
ماديه
قالت لاداره العسكريه وان ثلاثه اشخاص
قتلوا في قصف روسيا بالصواريخ على بلده
فوف شان بمنطقه
تشوغوياف في الاثناء اعلنت خدمه الطوارئ
الاوكرانيه عن ارتفاع حصيله ضحايا القصف
الذي اصاب مطعما وسط مدينه كراماتورز الى
عشره قتله بينهم اطفال اضافه الى عشرات
المصابين وفي دانياس قالت مراسله الجزيره
ان القوات الاوكرانيه قصفت احياء سكنيه في
المدينه بعشرات القذائف منذ الصباح
وبشان الاتهامات الاوكرانيه لروسيا
باستهداف مدنيين في كراماتورز قال
الكرملين ان القوات الروسيه لا تستهدف
البنيه التحتيه المدنيه وانما تستهدف فقط
المنشات المرتبطه بشكل او باخر بالبنيه
التحتيه العسكريه